hey
glad you guys
every country
actually
it's bigger
okay
when i was sworn in
yes
no
when i get home
is
okay
is
every angle
is
is
that's good appreciate it
what are they talking about
see
right after they invented that woman
from television
thank you
thank you
is
you know
[Music]
sorry
peace
yes
road
he's like
you can relate to that you have that
dream
which i continue to have four years of
age
oh
how are you
okay
you know
yes
um
okay
hey how are you mr president how are you
good afternoon before i begin today's
announcement uh
let me uh take a few moments to thank
all the law enforcement folks for
all they did the military personnel from
all across the federal state and local
agencies that secured yesterday's
inaugural activities
and a special thanks to the members of
the national guard from around the
country
it was an unprecedented situation hope
will
never have to be renewed again and
everyone
can handle the most professionalism and
duty and honor that you could be
expected
the president as president as
commander-in-chief i always
respect and revere their service and
that of their families
but now to today's announcement
vice president harris and i were joined
by members of our
kova 19 team response team and dr
tony fauci our chief covered medical
advisor
javier sarah excuse me our
nominee for secretary of health and
human services dr vivek murthy our
nominee for surgeon general
dr rochelle wolinski she's going to be
the director
for the centers for disease control
prevention and
dr marcella nunez smith who will be
leading our equity work and the covet
response
and jeff zeins and natalie quillin who
are managing this whole effort
yesterday yesterday during my inaugural
address
i offered a salient prayer and of silent
prayer it was both salient and silent
i thought it was important that people
understand what had happened
that we all pay tribute to the our
prayers for those four hundred thousand
americans
who've lost their lives in this pandemic
on tuesday uh jill and i kamal and doug
we stood at the reflecting pool
in front of the lincoln memorial and
joined americans all across the country
to remember
those 400 000 moms and dads husbands and
wives
children sons daughters and i said at
that moment
that to heal we must remember to heal
we must remember it's important to do
that as a nation
we must also act though not just
remember
yet for the past year we couldn't rely
on the federal government to act with
the urgency and focus and coordination
we needed
and we have seen the tragic cost of that
failure
three to four thousand deaths per day
to date more than 24 million americans
24 million americans have been infected
to put that in context
america makes up four percent of the
world's population
but 25 of the world's confirmed coven 19
cases and only 20 percent
of all the covet 19 deaths we have four
percent of the
world's population the pandemically the
pandemic excuse me has
disproportionately
impacted on blacks latinos and native
americans
who are about four times as likely to be
hospitalized and nearly three times more
likely to die
from the cover 19 pandemic than
white americans hospitals are out of
beds businesses are closed for good
schools are caught in between and while
the vaccine provides
so much hope the rollout has been a
dismal failure thus far
so i understand the despair and
frustration of so many americans
and how they're feeling i understand why
many governors
mayors county officials tribal leaders
feel like they're
left on their own without a clear
national plan to get them through the
crisis
let me be very clear things are going to
continue to get worse before they get
better
the memorial we uh we held two nights
ago
will not be our last one unfortunately
the death toll will likely top
500 000 next month the cases will
continue to mount
we didn't get into this mess overnight
that's going to take months for us to
turn things around
but let me be equally clear we will
get through this we will defeat this
pandemic
and to a nation waiting for action let
me be the clearest on this point
help is on the way today
today i am unveiling a national strategy
on covet 19
and executive actions to beat this
pandemic this plan reflects
the ideas i set forward during the
campaign
and further refined over the past three
months
it consists of my transitions teams the
task force tony fauci and the team
here today and other experts put this
plan together
our national strategy is comprehensive
it's based on science not politics
it's based on truth not denial and it's
detail
you can review this entire plan this
entire plan
by going to whitehouse.gov it is so
detailed it is over
100 it's 198 pages
and and for complete detail what we're
going to do
our plan starts with minding an
aggressive safe and effective
vaccination campaign
to meet our goal of administering 100
million shots
in our first hundred days in office
we're on day one
this will be one of the greatest
operational challenges our nation has
ever undertaken
and i'm committed to getting it done
we're committed to getting in time
and i explained as i explained last week
we'll move heaven and earth to get more
people vaccinated
for free and create more places for them
to get vaccinated
to mobilize more medical teams to get
shots on people's arms and to increase
vaccine supply
and get it out the door as fast as
possible
yesterday we got started we directed the
federal emergency management agency fema
to start standing up the first federally
supported community vaccination centers
with the goal of standing up 100 centers
within the next month
the centers for disease control and
prevention will launch the federal
pharmacy program
to make vaccines available to
communities in their local pharmacies
beginning early within the i think by
the 7th or 8th of february
in a very early february we'll also test
the department of health and human
services to prepare
and expand the pool of medical
professionals
who can administer the vaccine who can
administer the vaccine
and to ensure we have enough vaccinators
the people doing the vaccines
to meet the nation's needs and quickly
in addition to this effort our
administration
will be asking congress to fund the
for for the funds to grow the public
health
workforce we're also going to take
immediate steps to partner with
governors
mayors and other local officials who
we've been talking to all along
who are on the front lines of this fight
we direct we redirected fema to
establish a code response liaison
for each state which means every state
will have a point person
at the federal level to maximize
cooperation between the federal
government
and the states and where it falls short
to be made known about it may remain
known immediately
this is the model we use to respond to
hurricanes
hurricane sandy which i was deeply
involved with
and in just a few moments i'm going to
sign a declaration
to immediately begin reimbursing states
100 for the use of their national guards
to help code relief efforts
something democrats and republican
governors alike have called for
but the brutal truth is it's going to
take months before we can get the
majority of americans vaccinated
so while we increase vaccinations
we're going to take steps necessary now
to slow the spread of the disease as
well
one of our 100-day challenges is
asking the american people to mask up
for the first hundred days the next 99
days
the mass could become a partisan issue
unfortunately
but it's a patriotic act but for a few
months to wear a mask
no vaccines the fact is that the single
best thing we can do they're even more
important than the vaccines because they
take time to work
and if we do this as americans the
experts say by wearing a mask
from now until april we'd save more than
50
000 lives going forward 50 000
lives so i'm asking every american to
mask up
for the next hundred days yesterday i
signed an executive action
that requires mass and social distancing
on federal property
today we'll be signing an additional
executive action
to extend masking requirements on
interstate travel
like on trains planes and buses and
in light of the new covet variants that
we're you're learning about
we are we are we're instituting now
a new measure for individuals flying
into the united states
from other countries in addition to
wearing masks
everyone flying to the united states
from another country
will need to test before they get on
that plane
before they depart and quarantine when
they arrive in america our national plan
launches a full-scale war-time effort to
address the supply shortages
by ramping up production and protective
equipment syringes needles you name it
when i say wartime people kind of look
at me like wartime
well as i said last night four
hundred thousand americans have died
that's more than it died in all of world
war
two four hundred thousand
this is a wartime undertaking
today i'm signing an executive action to
use the defense production act
and all other available authorities to
direct all federal agencies
and private industry to accelerate the
making of everything this needs to
protect
test vaccinate and take care of our
people
well we've already identified suppliers
and we're working with them
to move the plan forward but look
our strategy includes a plan to safely
reopen schools and businesses
while protecting our workers today
we're directing the department of
education and the department of health
and human services
to immediately provide schools and
communities with
clear guidance and resources to safely
reopen
the schools and child care centers
we're putting and by the way when you do
that think of
all the people who can get back to work
be able to get back to work all the
mothers and single fathers are
staying home taking care of their
children
we're going to put full force of the
federal government
behind expanding testing by launching a
covet 19
pandemic testing board this effort will
ensure that we get tested
to where it is needed and where it's
needed most
helping schools and businesses reopen
safely and protecting the most
vulnerable like those who live in
long-term long-term care facilities
and for the millions of workers many of
whom are people of color
immigrants and low-wage workers who
continue to put their lives on the line
to keep this country going through the
pandemic
i'm calling for the enforcement of a
more stringent worker safety standards
so that you are better protected from
this virus
while you have to continue to work to
protect the rest of us
our plan also protects those most at
risk and works for everyone
of all races and urban and rural
communities alike
today i'm formalizing the health equity
task force
that we announced in the transition led
by the brilliant doctor
marcelo nunes-smith who ensures that
it's going to ensure that equality is at
the core of every decision we make
that includes addressing vaccine
hesitancy and building trust in
communities as well as fighting
disinformation campaigns
that are already underway above all
our plan is to restore public trust
we will make sure that science and
public health
scientists and public health experts
will speak directly to you that's why
you're going to hear a lot more from dr
fauci again
not from the president but from the real
genuine experts and scientists
we're going to make sure they work free
from political interference
and they make decisions strictly based
on science
and health care alone science and health
alone
not what the political consequences are
the vice president harris and i and our
entire administration
will always be honest and transparent
with you about both the good news and
the bad
we will level with you when we make a
mistake
we'll straight up say what happened
and i said at the outset the honest
truth is
we're still in a dark winter of this
pandemic
it's going to get worse before it gets
better it's going to take many months to
get where we need to be
progress from our plan will take time to
measure as people getting infected today
they don't show up as case counts for
weeks
and those who perish from this disease
die weeks after their exposure
despite the best intentions we're going
to face setbacks
which i will always explain to you but i
also
but also know we can do this if we come
together
that's why ultimately our plan is based
on
unity and all of us acting as one
nation it requires families
and neighbors looking out for one
another health care providers
and business and civic and religious and
civil rights organizations
and unions all relying together
on a common purpose with urgency
and purpose and resolve requires
reasserting our global leadership
which is why i took an action yesterday
for the united states to rejoin the
world health organization
and to re-establish our global pandemic
office in the national security council
it requires congress coming together to
provide the necessary funding
in the covert relief package and the
american rescue plan that i
will soon be sending to the congress i
know
these bold practical steps will not come
cheaply
but failing to do so will cost us so
much more dearly i look forward to
working with members of both parties in
the congress
we're in a national emergency it's time
we treat it like one
together the national plan as the united
states of america
as i said yesterday in my inaugural
address there are moments in history
when more is asked of a particular
generation more vascular as americans
than other times
we are in that moment now
history is going to measure whether
we're up to the task
i believe we are the american people
have given
so much already but i believe they're
ready to set
big goals and pursue them with courage
conviction and honesty because the
health of the nation is literally at
stake it's not hyperbole
i'm convinced the american people are
ready as well
to spare no effort no expense to get
this done
what could be more important more people
we vaccinate
and the faster we do it the sooner we
can put this pandemic behind us
the sooner we can build our economy back
and build it back better
and get back to our lives and to our
loved ones
we can do this we can do this if we
stand together
as fellow americans as the united as the
united states of america
so god bless those lost souls in this
pandemic
and their families all they're left
behind may god bless
all of you on the front lines who define
the best of who we are as americans
thank you very much now i'm going to go
over this desk and sign
these executive actions but again this
is the plan
this is the plan you can go online and
get it i know it's a lot of heavy
reading
but it's all laid out in stark detail
thank you
this executive order i'm signing is uh
strapping his supply chain
this next one is keeping workers safe
how to do that
this next one is insuring equitable
response
i guess i should take this out this way
the pins are gonna pop
can you give me
this next one is what i referenced about
traveling in america this is the
promoting safe travel
this nest one is setting up the pandemic
testing board
thank you
this next one is studying the safe
school clinician
this next one is dictating the
covert data that has to be maintained
and recorded
the next one is making sure
that the national guard and fema support
is available
this next one
relates to expanding access to care and
treatment for clover 19.
the last one is our
global response directive
um
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break
thank you guys thank you
thank you